[Music]
welcome to how the light gets in thank
you
so you're one of the pioneers of this
rising field called quantum biology many
people would have heard of molecular
biology but not necessarily of quantum
biology can you tell us what that is
yes quantum biology is um
a fusion between biology and quantum
physics and
it's come from the realization that at
its most fundamental level if you look
down into the center of
cells and the center of the organelles
and the center of molecules you come
down to particles
and actually
the action of life is really motion of
fundamental particles electrons and
protons
within biomolecules
and really life is all about directing
that motion to make
more life to keep us alive
and if you ask any physicist if you're
how to account for the motion of
fundamental particles like protons and
electrons they'll point you at quantum
mechanics
now i was brought up as a biochemist
that was my that was my training and we
knew nothing about
uh quantum mechanics
um but
graduates i became more and more
um
knowledgeable about the biology its most
fundamental level it occurred to me
quantum mechanics must be involved
when
dna is replicated particles move from
one place to another and they're
delivered along their paths by enzymes
some enzymes of molecular machines that
move particles
so they're quantum
machines and um
and really this whole field now as uh of
quantum biology has grown out of this
realization and the discovery
experimentally that quantum mechanical
effects are going on in living cells so
for example i'm looking at a tree
outside here and that some of of what
happens in photosynthesis involves the
motion of particles in a quantum
mechanical way in which they travel
along multiple paths simultaneously
and they can only do this in quantum
mechanics and this is what quantum
biology is about and is is quantum
biology therefore going to be as
revolutionary for the life sciences as
quantum mechanics was for physics
i mean i as i said i um was trained as a
biochemist biochemistry came as a fusion
between biology and chemistry
i think quantum biology is a fusion
between biology and physics and i think
that's the next big fusion in science
that we're going to see a lot coming out
of this interface between biology and
physics including quantum biology but
also many scanning devices etc
that are used in medicine already use
physics and quantum physics so
it is a very um
fruitful
interface
one of the one of the phenomena that
quantum biology
has is studying is quantum proton
tunneling in dna mutations can you tell
us what that is and
yeah this is
in fact what initially interested me in
um
quantum biology um
dna consists of a double helix we all
know and the genetic code is actually
the
substrate of the genetic code are
protons along the double helix
protons single particles along the
double helix where they are is
written the color of your eyes your
propensity for various diseases
and
is coded at a level of protons and
that's a quantum code
and it was speculated many years ago
that
mutations could be caused by protons
quantum mechanically tunneling from the
right to the wrong place
now that seems rather strange but um
protons normally would not be able to go
through a particular barrier
quantum mechanics the weirdness of
quantum mechanics allows them to go
through a barrier that if they were a
classical particle they wouldn't be able
to penetrate
and that can cause mutations if the
proton ends up in the wrong position in
the double helix then when it's
replicated
the dna strand that's made will be a
mistake we'll have a mistake in it we
call those mistakes mutations
so i became interested in whether this
was a cause of mutation 20 years ago
i went and gave a talk about it in the
physics department at the university of
surrey and they were very skeptical but
jim alkalini was in the audience and we
got together afterwards he was
interested in the idea we got together
afterwards eventually wrote a paper
about it i went on to write a book
quantum evolution and
20 years later the field is beginning to
blossom and now we have a quantum
biology doctoral training center at the
university of surrey with about 20 phd
students currently studying quantum
biology
people will have heard of heisenberg's
uncertainty principle schrodinger's cat
how did that how does that all apply to
the very small
level of life do those principles
shed light in how life functions at the
very small yeah it does i mean
as i mentioned the
photosynthesis seems to depend on on
an aspect of quantum mechanics and this
is a schrodinger's cat aspect of quantum
mechanics genius cat famously can be
alive and dead at the same time
as a
as a um
photon of light is transported from one
place to another in a leaf
it can go through a single path if it's
a classical particle but a quantum
mechanical particle can be in multiple
places at once just as shortly as cat
can be dead and alive at once in the in
the story and this being able to travel
by multiple paths at once
may allow photosynthesis to be more
efficient at capturing energy
and there is a mystery at the heart of
photosynthesis it an optimal conditions
is 100 efficient
no technology we have comes anywhere
close to how efficient that first step
it's not all of photosynthesis but that
first step is under optimal conditions
100 every photon of light is captured
nothing in technology approaches that
and quantum mechanics may account for it
early on many years ago roger penrose
wrote this book the new physics and the
emperor's
mind i if i remember the title correctly
and part of the idea was to try and
apply quantum mechanics to you know the
science of the mind the science of
consciousness you have interests in
consciousness as well does does quantum
biology promise a better understanding
of human consciousness it may do but
there's no evidence whatsoever at the
moment which would
convince me of that
as you say i do have an interesting
consciousness i have published a number
of papers
in the area of consciousness
and
none of them depend on quantum mechanics
when i've been speaking about quantum
biology recently and the biology is
going on at the level of of a few
particles you know protein could be here
or there within a dna molecule say
for quantum mechanics to account for
consciousness protons or electrons or
other particles would have to travel
would have to have this property across
your entire brain
and no physicist i know would um
think that that's at all possible so i
don't think the quantum mechanics or at
least we haven't got any evidence for
quantum mechanics being involved in
consciousness at the moment my own idea
is that it's the brain's electromagnetic
field the brain's electromagnetic field
is consciousness your mind is an
electromagnetic field so it's a physical
thing it's not the matter of the brain
it's the energy generated by neuron
firing an electromagnetic field the same
kind of information the same kind of
physicality that gets a signal from a
radio mass to your mobile phone for
example that's an electromagnetic field
that is in your brain and what i'm
claiming is the consciousness is that in
your brain it's that electromagnetic
field sitting within your brain
structure so would that be a kind of
emergent property as it were from the
other processes going on in the brain
yeah exactly and if you like the rest of
the brain can be considered as a kind of
computer that sends information down
wires called neurons
and but on top of that is the
electromagnetic field generated by all
of that neuron firing
and
this is where i believe
consciousness is
but it's not present in computers
because we don't use that information in
computers when computers are built we
try very hard to prevent what is called
electrical interference which is these
electromagnetic fields
interfering starting to
change the information that is in
processing that's going on
our brain has been coping with that
problem for
millions of years
and we think i think the solution it
found is to actually use that
information we call that our conscious
mind and it's actually this information
that's pulled into a if you're like a
pool of electromagnetism
where all of the information is held in
one single place this pool of
electromagnetism and it's now available
to all of the neurons in the brain
and that is where consciousness resides
let's shift from science to the
philosophy of science as it were you
have a new book
that's called life is simple how o comes
razor set science free and unlocked the
universe can you remind us briefly what
uh ocum's razor principle is yes it's
named after a chap called william of
ockham who was a franciscan fire friar
born around 13 1285
so he lived in the
13th 14th century and he came up with
the principle well he didn't come up
with many other people before him even
the ancient greeks had a preference for
simplicity
but it was a fairly
weak preference william moroccan um
he studied um
theology at oxford at that time theology
was called the queen of sciences
and that was because there was no
difference between science and theology
and scholars studied questions such as
you know what angels are made of what
the gates of heaven are made of
and this was considered the part of
science aquinas a generation or so
earlier
had supposedly proved god
the existence of god in five different
ways mostly taken from aristotle
every thing that moves is moved by
another so there must be a first mover
and
aristotle
also said that everything has a purpose
so there must be a purpose to everything
and he called both god
william welcome came along and said no
this is all nonsense
um
the
first mover argument the final cause
argument he decimated all of those
saying for example that objects don't
need causes they're just there a fire is
hot it doesn't need a cause to be hot
it's just hot
so he used his razor to do that he
eliminated causes that were not
necessary and his razer occam's razor
often uh described in in the way our
entities should not be multiplied beyond
necessity
so if you don't need a final cause to
explain things in the world get rid of
it
and at that time also
um
people were philosophers were what were
called philosophical realists and they
believed that every object like a circle
has a universal a kind of platonic form
of circle hiding behind it
and um
and so a a father has a universal of
fatherness that king has a universal
royalty and the whole world was suffused
with
these universals everything had these
hidden universals
when moroccan said no none of them exist
that was important because
in the medieval world
kings were kings because they held this
universal of kingship which they could
pass on to their children so the whole
structure of the medieval world depended
on this notion of universals that were
these invisible entities
um william bockham said they don't exist
and that stripped away a lot of the
metaphysical baggage of the medieval
world
and then he went on to say that there
are two ways of working out the world
one is science and we do it with reason
we get rid of all the baggage so we use
occam's razor to get rid of all the
stuff you don't need
that's science
on the other hand he was a franciscan
friar there is religion and theology and
there you can believe in angels you can
believe in gods or whatever you like
but don't mix it up with science
all the scientists in the subsequent
centuries took that same approach
they delivered simpler solutions in
their science and they kept religion and
theology out of it and this was really
the turning point of science so my book
i claim it is the fundamental
uh premise of science is simplicity
simplicity is a kind of human value
almost you might say an aesthetic value
right so how do we explain the fact that
it's such a good guide to how the world
outside is there's probably many
explanations one of them it can be
explained in bayesian inference which is
down to thomas bates another cleric of
course but uh yeah he came up with this
uh form of statistics now i'll explain
it with two dice
they're invisible dice at the moment
i've got the real ones in my bag but we
won't bother those one dice is as normal
six sided dice the other is a sixty
sided dice
and then unseen to you i will throw one
of these dice okay and the number that
comes comes up i will say is a five
now which dice have i thrown
people will realize of course it's gonna
be the six sided dice because there's
only six different numbers it can throw
the 60-sided dice there are 60 different
numbers it can throw that's a smaller
probability smaller probability of
throwing the 5.
so
this comes out in bayesian reasoning the
likelihood function the likelihood
function is the probability of the data
given the model so the model six sided
dice probability one and six throwing a
five the model 60 sided dice probability
of one 160 of throne of five
and bayesian reasoning says choose the
simplest because it's the most likely so
for example that was used then in the
same kind of reasoning was used to argue
for by copernicus to argue for
heliocentricity the model he had
the heliocentric model was no
better at making predictions in the
heavens than ptolemy's model
but he argued that it was simpler
so that argument that it has fewer parts
to turn to change so it has a higher
probability of of generating the data if
it didn't fits it of course if it
doesn't fit then you've got to have a
little complex model but if your simple
model fits
you could should go with that all of
science does that
john joe mcfadden thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
[Music]